guillaume solar pelletier travail à la
pige comme vidéaste au printemps la pcu
lui a été d'une grande aide
moi ça m'a permis de sourire pendant la
pandémie parce que pour mon domaine tout
était mort socialement et maintenant la
nouvelle prestation canadienne de
relance économique lui offre un nouveau
filet de sécurité
personnellement j'ai besoin mentalement
d'heures travaillées sauf qu'avec c'est
surtout l'enjeu avec les gars de risque
les écoles ce qui ferme la pcr eux
s'adresse entre autres aux travailleurs
autonomes et contractuels qui ne sont
pas éligibles à l'assurance emploi pour
y être admis il faut avoir été dans
l'incapacité de travailler à cause de la
pandémie ou avoir enregistré une baisse
de 50% de son revenu
du côté des salariés c'est mieux ciblés
parce que maintenant on exige qu'il soit
la recherche d'un emploi et du côté des
gens qui ne se qualifie pas l'assurance
emploi du côté de la prestation
canadienne de relance économique
mais là on a rajouté des critères
français des mesures un peu pauvre
resserrer un peu les les programmes dave
la première journée du programme a été
marqué par des difficultés informatiques
les problèmes ont été résolus en après
midi à date quand même simple
fonctionnement pour s'inscrire
sauf que ça reste à marie pierre forest
ne crache pas sur l'aide de la pcr eux
mais elle voudrait que le gouvernement
repenser sa manière d'aider les secteurs
les plus touchés
je pense qu'il réduit plus poussées
latche que je donnais des shakur genre
de données de l'aide aux entreprises
on devait l'entreprise puis plus
précisément aux domaines qui sont le
plus touchés le domaine culturel égal au
guillaume solaire petty jusque un
programme comme la pcr est essentielle
si le dernier recours si tu prends des
travailleurs autonomes ou des
travailleurs autonomes mères
monoparentales mais décoincer les
personnes admissibles à la pcr eux
auront droit à 500 $ par semaine pour
une durée maximale de 26 semaines parce
qu'ils m'accusent à belleroche radio
canada montréal